May be seated.
Good morning. Welcome church family. How are you today?
Great, great, great. It's good to see you here.
Visitors, those of you who aren't regularly attending,
our body of believers, we welcome you.
We thank you for choosing to worship with us today,
and we ask a favor of you though we want to get to know you.
We, we want to know who you are.
We want to know how we might be able
to minister and care for you.
We might, uh, be able to pray for you.
If you would just share something about
yourself, we'd appreciate it.
You can do that on the cards in the back
of the seat in front of you,
or you can do that, uh,
through the lobby on the other side at the new here, uh,
centers tables where members
of our church should warmly greet you.
And I hope you have already been warmly greeted this morning
as, uh, I prepared for this sermon.
I, I just had to think
and give thanks to the Lord for his leadership
and the lives of our parents, Cheryl and mine
and in our lives
because we cannot recall a single day
or time that we have not been a part of the church.
That's a massive blessing for us.
It's an encouragement that we've received, uh,
as our parents set that example that is meaningful to us.
And we can recall many instances
where our families cared for others.
I think about when my childhood,
when my mother would take meals to people
and she would help clean their homes
whenever uh, they had need
and found themselves in a difficult situation.
I think specifically also
of one time on a Wednesday evening when we were
after church at the church,
we were at Northwest Oklahoma City at the time
and we used to spend the evenings
after the worship in the gymnasium
with all the kids enjoying one another
and all the dads enjoying one another
and fellowshipping playing basketball
or dodge ball or some crazy thing.
And my father, who I would say has quite an aversion
to blood, was found missing.
Instead, he had gone outside
because he had heard that there was a motorcycle accident in
the median, uh, outside of our church
and the motorcycle accident, uh, the person
that was involved needed care
and he brought him into the gym
and through the gym into the locker room where my father
and a bunch of other men
and women could take care of this man while he was awaiting
some other more serious and needed medical care.
I also think about Cheryl's family in the example
that her parents give their generosity, their care
for their family members, for the people in their community,
how they provide in many ways for their church, uh, family,
even today opening their home on a regular basis
for their community group.
You'll find out in a moment why that is so unusual.
That example happened, this event happened
for our family in January of 1995.
Cheryl and I were in our second year of marriage.
We were sitting in our apartment still water.
I'm certain that we were studying, trying
to finish our degree, but as we were there,
we received a phone call that evening
and the phone call was a somber, immediate,
urgent phone call.
Cheryl's father and brother had been in a serious
one vehicle rollover accident,
and Cheryl's father had been critically injured
and was being life flighted to Oklahoma City
to be at Baptist Medical Center in the emergency room.
So we got in the car and we rushed to Oklahoma City
to meet him there and Cheryl's mom,
and that's when we found out that Sheryl's father
had been paralyzed from the neck down.
He'd be a quadriplegic for the rest of his life.
He would require significant treatment, rehab,
and all of the things that go along with that.
Travel from Oklahoma City to Dallas
and later to Tulsa and then back home.
During that time though, we got
to once again witness the church being the church
because they were now caring
for our family.
The church that Cheryl's parents belonged
to were the same church that my parents had belonged
to that we had met in.
And these people recognized at this point
that life would never be the same for Roger and Judy
and Alan and Shelly and Cheryl and our families.
The church provided meals for a very long time
after the accident.
Of course that's a a pretty common
thing that we do as Baptist.
We feel like fellowship is uh, spelled FOOD
and it is in many cases, so don't stop that, right?
But at the same time, what they recognized in knowing that,
uh, life would not be the same, they recognize
that the house that Roger and Judy lived in
and still live in to this day was insufficient
to bring a quadriplegic into the house
and be able to care for them.
So they involved themselves
and engaged in a pretty significant remodel of the house,
taking a very large front bedroom
and converting that front bedroom into a rehab care room
with a handicap accessible bathroom attached
that you could pull a wheelchair into and bathe and care
and brush teeth and all of the things that would need
to to be done.
It was amazing. It was such a great example
of actions of love that were unprovoked
and genuine toward Roger
and Judy, Alan, Shelly, and our family.
This is just an example of
what we're gonna talk about today in verses 10
and 15 of Romans 12.
As we do though, we need to more fully appreciate what it is
that Paul is teaching and exhorting the Romans.
So we're gonna start by reading all of Romans 12, one
through 15 as we do.
If you are able to stand, please do so in honor
of the reading of God's word.
Romans 12 verse one.
I appeal to you, therefore brothers, by the mercies of God
to prevent, present your bodies as a living sacrifice,
holy and acceptable to God, which is your spiritual worship.
Do not be conformed to this world,
but be transformed by the renewal of your mind that
by testing you may discern what is the will of God,
what is good and acceptable
and perfect for by the grace given to me, I say
to everyone among you not to think
of himself more highly than he ought to think,
but to think with sober judgment, each according
to the measures or to the measure of faith
that God has assigned for us in one body,
we have many members and the members do not all
have the same function.
So we though many are one body in Christ
and individually members one of another, having gifts
that differ according to the grace given to us.
Let us use them if prophecy and proportion to our faith.
If service in our serving, the one
who teaches in his teaching, the one
who exhorts in his exhortation, the one
who contin contributes in generosity, the one who leads
with zeal, the one who does acts of mercy with cheerfulness.
Let love be genuine. Abhor what is evil.
Hold fast to what is good.
Love one another with brotherly affection.
Outdo one another in showing honor.
Do not be thoughtful and zeal. Be fervent in spirit.
Serve the Lord, rejoice in hope.
Be patient in tribulation. Be constant in prayer.
Contribute to the needs of the saints
and seek to show hospitality.
Bless those who persecute you. Bless and do not curse them.
Rejoice with those who rejoice, weep with those who weep.
That's Romans 12, one through 15. Thank you.
You may be seated
Today we'll focus on loving one another in the first half
of verse 10 and caring for others around us in verse 15,
both rejoicing and weeping.
But first, before we do as we need to really understand
and appreciate this particular instruction by Paul, we need
to review some important fundamentals.
Those fundamentals start in verse two for us today
where we see that our love for one another
and others is a transformed love.
Verse two tells us, do not be conformed to this world.
This English word conformed is translated
from a Greek word system Zo.
Okay? True confessions here.
I am not a Greek scholar.
There may be some of you here today who are, if you are
and I pronounce something incorrectly, please just giggle
and give me the grace to move on.
But Cisco matzo is a word that can be defined as to form
or mold one's behavior in accordance with
a particular pattern
or set of standards to shape one's behavior
to conform one's life.
The image I get here is an image of being
pressed into the world, into this mold.
When I was a consultant, I used to consult
with manufacturing companies around our state
and the surrounding states, and I got the benefit
and the privilege of, uh, consulting
with many household names
that you would know and understand.
But one of them that you probably wouldn't recognize is one
that I think is particularly interesting in light
of this instruction.
It's a little company in Miami, Oklahoma that
made its claim to fame in World War II by manufacturing
what we know as the jerry can, a metal gas can
that was used to carry fuel around the countryside
and the back of Jeeps and other vehicles to allow us to, uh,
power these vehicles throughout the battlefields.
But they had con uh, transformed their manufacturing process
for manufacturing in metal products
to manufacturing in plastic products that we now use today.
So their key product were plastic gas cans.
And as they had con uh, changed their manufacturing process,
they had now used what's known as extrusion molding
and extrusion molding.
What it di is is they have these big gigantic bins
of plastic pellets that are different colors.
Some of them white, some of them red, some of them blue
for different purposes,
and they feed those into a vacuum system
and bring them into a heating apparatus.
And that heating apparatus puts them in a consistency
that is able to extrude a tube out
of the ceiling, basically to come into a series
of molds that clamp down.
And as the tube comes in
and the molds clamp around, air is blown in
and the um, those pellets
that were melted now form into the side of the molds.
So when they pull the molds away, there is a gas can.
But when they pull the molds away and we saw
and I saw those gas cans,
what I also recognized was there was an edge
around the gas can of excess materials in every
instance and example in their particular process,
they would try desperately to reuse and recycle that excess,
but oftentimes they would just have to cut it away
and discard it.
That's an important picture for me
because as I think about those verses between verse two
and verse nine where we're encouraged
and exhorted to use our gifts to unify
and bind the body of believers,
and I think about where Paul is telling us not
to be conformed to this world,
what I think about is I think about
that gas can coming out with the excess.
If we are conformed
and pressed into this world,
what happens is we're pressed into a mold we were not
intended to be formed into,
and there is always excess that comes around the edges.
And the excess that we have that is carved away by the world
as not useful as unmeaningful, as even
weakness is that we have is discarded.
And that discard happens to be many of the gifts, many
of the the equipping ways that God has designed us
to serve and minister to our body of believers
and those people that we live around.
If we allow ourselves to be conformed to the world
around us, we cannot fulfill the design that God has for us.
We will come out looking like something entirely different
than what we were intended to look like
and we will lack the full substance of
what God intended for us to have.
But instead, Paul goes on in verse two to tell us to
be transformed.
As John shared several weeks ago,
the English word transformed is translated from a Greek
word metamorpho O.
This word can be defined as the change, uh,
to change the essential form or nature of something.
It's the the same word
that we derive our word metamorphosis from
Contrast, this change to being conformed
in that instance, that example of being conformed,
particularly in the context
of those plastic beads being put into a gap,
made into a gas can.
What we see is their real makeup hasn't really changed.
They're still plastic. They're kind of joined together
with other plastic to make these gas cans,
but they're still plastic.
They're just in a different form, okay?
They look a little bit different,
but if we're transformed, we will be different.
What's interesting here is that earlier in this letter
to the Romans, Paul in verse 29 of chapter eight
actually instructs the Roman believers to be conformed.
But in this point he doesn't just instruct them
to be conformed, he instructs him
to be conformed into the image of Jesus,
into the likeness of him.
So we're not to be conformed to this world,
but we are to be transformed or
or changed, were to be conformed into the image of the sun.
In this case conformed in verse 29
or chapter eight is not
matzo, it's a different word.
Amorphous is the word in Greek is translated here
and this word means pertaining to
that which has a similar form or nature.
Does that sound familiar?
It reminds me of Genesis chapter one verses 26
and 27 where we're told that then God said,
let us make man in our image after our likeness
and let them have dominion over the fish of the sea
and over the birds of the heavens and over the livestock
and over all the earth
and over every creeping thing that creeps on the earth.
So God created man in his image, in the image of God,
he created him, male and female, he created them.
Genesis 1 26 and 27.
It is in God's image then that we were
and are created.
But unfortunately, sin has marred that image.
It's unrecognizable.
In fact, our allowing ourselves
to be conformed to this world continues
to make his image unrecognizable.
William Hendrickson
and his commentary on Romans actually translates this verse
as stop allowing yourselves to be conformed
to this world when we're allowing
ourselves to be conformed.
We are not who it is that God intended us to be.
We need to be transformed.
We need to be changed,
and it's into God's image that we need to changed.
There's not one there of us that has ever perfectly
exemplified this, but there is one who has
and that one who has is in fact
and indeed if I can get it out of my pocket, the
plumb line that John's been talking about, it's Jesus,
that straight plumb line example.
So as we look at these verses
and we think about what it is we are to
exemplify to the world, we need to think
and look at it in terms of who Jesus was, who Jesus is,
and our transformed love should be first for one another.
That's what Paul tells us in verse 10,
Paul instructs the Roman of believers here
to love one another with brotherly affection.
This love is not the same love as in verse nine.
Verse nine is agape love this enduring, everlasting,
undeserved love.
In this case, this is a brotherly love,
a love for one another.
And in verse 10, he uses this Greek word philoso ghost
that can be translated pertaining to love
or affection for those closely related to one, particularly
one's immediate family.
Paul telling the Roman believers to love one another,
one another, like they love their own family.
How is it that we love our family?
Can you guys imagine that you guys see
that picture in your mind right now?
How does that compare to
how we love one another within this family
of believers within this body?
I see it and I observe it on a regular basis.
I know of needs and situations that our body
of believers absolutely treats one another like family
members, but it's something we need
to ask ourselves on a daily basis if our love
for the church is different than our love for the family.
Are we loving toward one another?
Are we warmly devoted to one another?
Affectionate? Do we
show resilient, caring, love in good times and bad?
Consider this in light of verse nine that also Paul says,
let love be genuine.
This word genuine is translated from altos.
That word means pertaining to being genuine and sincere
and hence lacking in pretense or show.
Paul's telling us that our love should be without hypocrisy.
In other words, our words of saying, I love you brother,
I love you, sister, our words of telling someone
that we care for them should actually be followed
with action and our actions
should mimic those words.
How we greet one another, how we support one another,
how we enjoy one another, and how we care for one another.
Think about some examples with me.
We, uh, as elders when we meet on Tuesday nights,
we spend a few minutes at the beginning of our meetings
and uh, those minutes are in devotion.
And most recently crisscross has been leading us
through Exodus chapter 34,
and we've been talking about the character traits of God
that are displayed to us in Exodus 34 6.
The character trait we talked about this past Tuesday
as we met was that God shows
steadfast love.
And in verse seven, we find
that steadfast love is manifest toward us in forgiveness.
So do we manifest steadfast love, forgiveness to those
in our body of believers exemplifying what God has showed
to us following the image that we were created in.
Think about Matthew chapter 12 verses 46 through 50
record where Jesus was approached by a man who's saying
that your mother and your brothers wanna speak with you.
And Jesus' response to them, this man was who are my mother
and my brothers aren't my mother
and my brothers, those who do the will of my father,
those who do the will of my father, believers the church.
This is the same people that Paul is calling one another
in this passage in Romans 12,
Jesus also shared times of joy and rest with his disciples.
We find this in Mark chapter six
and Luke chapter 10,
where Jesus had sent out the 72 disciples two by two.
He gave them specific instruction
and guidance on what they were to do
and how they were to do it, even how they were
to respond when they were not welcomed at a different place.
And as they returned telling Jesus of what the result
of their proclaiming, repentance and casting out demons
and healing, many was Jesus rejoiced
with them and called them to a time of rest.
We also see in the last supper a time of rest
and joy that Jesus had with his disciples
where he called them before what he knew would be
his last days on earth before his ascension,
before his death and burial and mistreatment
and hatred that all showed him we're told of
how he spent this time of solitude
with them enjoying their company
and fellowship in the upper room.
And then we're told in Acts chapter two verses 42
through 47, how the early church mimicked
and mirrored exactly the example of
what Jesus had showed them we're told in Acts two,
and they devoted themselves to the apostles teaching
and the fellowship to the breaking of bread and the prayers
and all came upon every soul and many wonders
and signs were being done through the apostles
and all who believe were together
and had all things in common,
and they were selling their possessions and belongings
and distributing the proceeds to all as any had need.
And day by day, attending the temple together
and breaking bread in their homes, they received their food
with glad and generous hearts, praising God
and having favor with all the people
and the Lord added to their number day
by day those who are being saved.
These passages give us some examples of
what brotherly affection is.
It's caring for one another that is steadfast,
meaning not wavering, regardless of good times or bad.
It's love for whoever does the will,
the father's will for one another.
It's a love that acts in obedience to Jesus
and celebrates what the Lord accomplishes
through that obedience.
It's a love that enjoys times of peace together,
despite times of trouble
and trials that we are confident will come.
It's a love that is devoted implying commitment
and sacrifice, working to together to understand
and rightly divide the scriptures, sharing the blessings
and benefits of being a unified body of believers,
sharing all things to ensure provision for each member
of the body daily, engaging in worship and fellowship
and faith, having glad hearts
overflowing in generosity, praising God
and having favor with all the people.
It's this point, having favor with all the people
that is the result
and benefit of showing love
for others
We're called the deep sacrificial love
as we're being reshaped, transformed
and conformed into his likeness, his nature, his image,
our transformation results in a different kind of love.
Not one that is meant by the world, where the world means it
to be some emotional connection, but a real
and true connection to one another where we genuinely care
it's different kind of love than
what we see displayed in the world.
Jesus rejoiced and wept with his disciples for sure,
but also rejoiced and wept with others.
Let's take a look at some examples.
As Jesus rejoiced with others,
Paul starts in verse 15
and tells us to rejoice with those who rejoice.
This word rejoice is translated from a Greek word,
uh, called Cairo.
Cairo means to enjoy a state of happiness and wellbeing,
and it has implicit in it, not just those times
of significant greatness and benefit,
but times of just mere peace
and lack of turmoil to enjoy with one another.
Jesus did this with others who were not as disciples.
Remember the wedding feast at Cana in John chapter two
where Jesus was celebrating with all those
who were at the wedding and performed
what we now know is his first recorded miracle.
How about the private teaching in
parables that Jesus shared?
Imagine sitting on our patio with our neighbors,
telling stories of our lives what God has done in us
and what we know to be true about him.
That's what I envision.
There would've been disciples
and not disciples alike that were there.
We know those people that weren't disciples were there
because Jesus in those moments was criticized
and he was chastised for teaching in the way he was teaching
and teaching what he was teaching, even teaching
with authority as he were God and he is.
Remember Jesus eating with tax collectors and sinners.
Jesus dying with Matthew at his house, a tax collector
with many other tax collectors as well,
and what the people called sinners.
When the Pharisees questioned Jesus about it, Jesus said,
it is not the healthy who need a doctor but the sick.
I have not come to call the righteous but sinners.
And we should also recall when Jesus came into Zia's house,
invited himself there,
and that was the moment where that interaction with Jesus
that resulted in Zacchaeus repentance,
loving Christ, should overflow into rejoicing
with other people, genuine times of happiness and wellbeing.
Like though Jesus wept with others.
Paul tells us in the second half of verse 15 that we're
to weep with those who weep
To weep is translated from a Greek word called cla.
Clio means, uh, to weep with the clear implication
of shedding tears.
Deep sorrow is what we would think.
And examples of Jesus' life exist here too, where Jesus
wept with others.
First John 11, where Jesus wept because of Lazarus's death.
He didn't need to weep. Think about this.
Jesus knew what the outcome would be.
Jesus was going to perform it himself.
Jesus waited so that he could perform it,
but yet he still entered into their sorrow.
He still entered into their weeping at that time
with Mary and Martha
and all of the others that mourned Lazarus death.
And Luke chapter 22, we see this moment
and Jesus trials where Jesus looks up from the trials
and catches Peter's eye the moment
after he's indeed
denied Christ for the third time.
And we're told of Peter's sorrow in that
his embarrassment, his guilt that he felt,
but I'm certain that Jesus likewise felt the sorrow
and the pain in the similar way that Peter did.
And finally we see in Matthew chapter 23,
where Jesus wept over Jerusalem
because he knew that Jerusalem would not believe
and that they would have a coming judgment.
Okay, I have an apology to give you
at the beginning when I brought you into, uh, this,
uh, study together.
I left you in 1995, middle schoolers. That means 1995.
There was no, uh, smartphone.
There was no Minecraft,
and there was, you know, no Netflix, certainly no Netflix.
I apologize for leaving you there,
but I want you to fast forward for a minute
to January of 2021.
In January of 2021, I was at work one afternoon
and my father called, that was not something
that was a typical usual event.
He, he was kind and has always been kind to honor my workday
and, uh, not interrupt.
So I knew when he called, it was something that was, uh,
serious and, and needed my attention
as I answered the phone.
He explained that he
and my mom had been to the doctor to get their first
of the COVID vaccinations.
And afterward they had gone to lunch and stopped
and enjoyed a bit of time.
And at lunch, my mother had had a
significant medical event.
Something we would later learn
was a ruptured cerebral aneurysm.
She was admitted to care at OU Medical Center,
but due to COVID restrictions, she was alone
for weeks, her surgeries,
her recovery and therapy
with no family member by her side.
Once again, it was during that time
that our family saw the church
respond and react with the love of Jesus.
We have members in our church body
who didn't know my parents.
They were generous to help translate the diagnosis,
to help explain the treatments, to help tell us
of the risks, to check on us
and my father to provide meals
and most importantly to me, to visit my mother
during their workday at OU Medical Center facilities.
We had tangibly received again,
the unprovoked
and genuine love of Christ through the church.
And my parents are believers.
So it might seem kind of weird
that I'm fitting this into a time when we're learning
and teaching about loving others who aren't a part
of the believing body.
But let me tell you something,
those church members at Henderson Hills that cared for us
during this time period, I never once
recall that they asked if my parents were believers.
They just acted. They just loved.
They just cared.
They were simply displaying the love of Jesus to others,
helping make sense of medical facts that neither training
nor experience nor emotion would allow us to process
meeting needs that couldn't be met by us in the moment
and providing encouragement in a discouraging experience.
And I recognize one other thing about their actions.
The love these church members were exhibiting incorporated
something that I have often missed.
It's in this word translated weep.
The Greek word has an emphasis not only on tears,
but the Greek word actually has an emphasis on the noise
accompanying the weeping.
It's an audible thing.
As I've thought and wrestled
and prayed through this while preparing for today,
I'm convinced that the emphasis isn't really on
an encouragement to go around and crying out loud
and beating our breasts and wailing at the top of our lungs.
That's not helpful, that's not edifying,
that doesn't show others any real measure
of the love displayed by Jesus.
Instead, I'm convinced that this emphasis is on the fact
that love involves interaction.
Knowing that our Bibles are translations of manuscripts
and the manuscripts, copies of original scrolls and poems
and letters that were written, I tend
to focus on specific words to help me understand what it is
that God would direct to me that I need
to grasp from a verse or a passage.
I'm sure you can see that as we've walked
through this passage today, but I've skipped a word
and I think it's a really important word.
It's the word with in the English language.
We know that with is a preposition that connects to things.
But in the Greek, this word has some added flavor
that we need to appreciate
with is translated from a word meta in Greek.
That word meta means it's a marker
of an associative relationship, usually with the implication
of being in the company, of someone
Loving, like Jesus means.
Being present and engaged with others
physically, emotionally, and spiritually.
Church isn't just a Sunday gathering and our neighborhoods
and communities aren't just plots of land
that we build houses, stores, and restaurants on.
As we seek to love Christ more this year,
let's seek to love like Jesus does,
like the plumb line that he has exhibited to us
that we see in scripture as we come to love him more.
Let's be proactive to check in with people when you know
of events in their lives, both good and bad.
When you have just not seen them very often,
let's celebrate big moments and ordinary moments alike.
Let's learn to be present in their struggles.
This presence weeping with bearing their burdens
with something.
Ryan Whitaker calls the ministry of presence.
Who is it that we need to invest our time with and in?
Who do we need to rejoice with this week?
And who do we need to be present for as they hurt?
Lord God, help us to love, uh Christ more
by loving one another and the world
around us like you do us.
Amen.